الامم المتحده تستبق الذكرى الاولى للحرب
بقرار يطالب روسيا بالانسحاب الفوري من
اوكرانيا
وقمه افتراضيه لمجموعه السبع لدعم
خطه سلام صينيه تطالب بعدم اللجوء للنووي
واستئناف المفاوضات والتوصل لتسويه سلميه
بين موسكو وكيف
مصادر ايرانيات تؤكد استهداف طائره مسيره
لسياره قرب كرج تقل قائد الوحده 400 بفيلق
القدس
[موسيقى]
ثم طابت اوقاتكم اهلا بكم الى هذه النشره
الاخباريه من العربيه اقرت الجمعيه العمل
للامم المتحده باغلبيه كبيره مشروعه قرار
يطالب روسيا مجددا بسحب قواتها من
اوكرانيا ويدعو لوقف القتال قرار الجمعيه
العامه تبنته نحو 60 دوله واقرته الجمعيه
اليوم باغلبيه 141 دوله ضد سبع دول فقط مع
امتناع اثنين واثنتين دوله عن التصويت كما
اكد القرار في معظمه على مبادئ ميثاق
الامم المتحده
الذي يضمن السلام الشامل والعادل والدائم
في اوكرانيا
الجمعيه العامه توافق باغلبيه ساحقه على
ادانه روسيا القرار تبنته نحو 60 دوله
واقرته باغلبيه 141 دوله ضد سبع دول فقط
مع امتناع 32 دوله عن التصويت
القرار اكد ان مبادئ ميثاق الامم المتحده
هي من تضمن السلامه الشامل والعادل
والدائم في اوكرانيا
اكد القرار ايضا على الالتزام بالسياده
واستقلال ووحده اراضي اوكرانيا ضمن حدود
دوليه معترف بها
القرار طلب بالانسحاب الفوري والكامل وغير
المشروط للقوات الروسيه من الاراضي
الاوكرانيه
شمل القرار ايضا اسرى الحرب من الطرفين
الروسي والاوكراني وطلب بمعاملتهم وفقا
لمعاهدات جناز لعام
القرار شدد على ضروره واهميه محاسبه
المسؤولين عن اشد الجرائم خطوره وفقا
للقانون الدولي
عن نتيجه التصويت والرساله واضحه لا يهم
تفعله روسيا من محاولات لتقويض النظام
الدولي والتحالف الداعم لوحده اراضي
اوكرانيا لكنها تفشل مره تلو الاخرى
التحالف موجود وسيبقى طالما كانت هناك
رغبه في ان تنتصر اوكرانيا في جهودها ليس
للدفاع عن نفسها فقط بل ايضا للدفاع عن
ميثاق الامم المتحده ومبادئه
هذه الاغلبيه الساحقه من المجتمع الدولي
تؤكد دعمها الكبير لاوكرانيا التي بات
الضحيه للعدوان الروسي وقد حاولت روسيا
خلال الاسبوع باكمله تشتيت انتباه الامم
المتحده وتعطيلها بالمناورات لقد فشلت مره
اخرى
تصويت اليوم كان تاريخ حقا لقد رايت بعض
مرور عام على غزو روسيا غير القانوني وغير
المبرر والواسع النطاق لاوكرانيا ان دول
العالم تقف مع اوكرانيا قررت هذه الدول
141 طلبا واضحا لروسيا وجوب الانسحاب
الفوري والكامل وغير المشروط من الاراضي
الاوكرانيه المعترف بها دوليا ارسل قواتك
الى بلادك وانهي هذه الحرب
ومع حلول الذكرى الاولى للحرب في اوكرانيا
يعقد الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن اليوم
اجتماعا افتراضيا مع قاده مجموعه السبع
حول اوكرانيا
وقالت المتحدثه باسم البيت الابيض كريم
جون ان الولايات المتحده ستعلن حزمه
عقوبات واسعه النطاق ضد روسيا تشمل بنوكا
وشركات للدفاع وتكنولوجيا
مستشار الامن القومي في البيت الابيض جيك
سوليفان اعلن ان واشنطن ستقدم مساعدات
امنيه وعسكريه لاوكرانيا بقيمه 2 مليار
دولار واضاف سوليبان في مقابله مع الاعلام
الامريكي ان الولايات المتحده تنظر في
جميع احتياجات اوكرانيا الضروريه
لمساعدتها على كسب الحرب
دعا رئيس الوزراء
البريطانيك مجموعه السبع الى التحرك بشكل
اسرع في تسليح القوات الاوكرانيه
بالمدفعيه والمدرعات والدفاع الجوي وشدد
سوناك على ضروره تزويد كيف باسلحه ذات مدى
اطول لكي تحصل على ميزه حاسمه في ساحه
المعركه
دعت صين روسيا واوكرانيا الى اجراء
محادثات سلام في اقرب وقت ممكن كما دعت
الصين روسيا واوكرانيا لتفادي شن هجمات ضد
المدنيين والمنشات المدنيه وحضرت الخارجيه
الصينيه من استخدام الاسلحه النوويه في
الحرب الاوكرانيه وقالت انه يجب على جميع
الاطراف دعم روسيا واوكرانيا في العمل في
نفس الاتجاه واستئناف المفاوضات والتوصل
لتسويه سلميه
وعشيه مرور عاما على الحرب وفي خطابه
المسائي اقر الرئيس الاوكراني فلودي
مارزلنسكي بصعوبه الوضع العسكري على جبهتي
الشرق والجنوب قال ان الوضع العسكري في
جنوب اوكرانيا خطير للغايه لكن القوات
الاوكرانيه قادره على صد الغزاه مشيرا الى
ان القوات الروسيه قصفت مدينه خيرسون
وتركت نحو اربعين الف شخص دون تدفئه او
طاقه وقال زلينسكي ان اعمال الاصلاح في
خيرسون ستستمر حتى تعود التدفئه للسكان
الاوضاع الميدانيه على جبهه الشرق مؤلمه
وصعب جدا نبذل قصار جهدنا للصم اما في
الجنوب فالوضع العسكري على بعض الجبهات
خطير للغايه ولكن قواتنا قادره على صد
الغزاه
اثار مصطلح تالوت النووي تكهنات كثيره في
الاوساط السياسيه بعدما تعهد الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين بتحسينه وتطويره
خلال اجتماع موسع لقيادات وزاره الدفاع
نشاهد التفاصيل لاحدث اسلحه الثالوث
النووي التي تملكها موسكو
الثالوث النووي مصطلح اشعل التوتر من جديد
في اوكرانيا بعد ان تعهد الرئيس الروسي
بتطويره للحفاظ على سياده روسيا ووحده
اراضيها
هذا المصطلح اثار تكهنات عده في الاوساط
السياسيه لما قد يشكله من تهديد للعواصم
الغربيه ففي العقيده العسكريه الروسيه
يتكون الثالث النووي من ثلاثه انواع من
الاسلحه الردعيه هذه الاسلحه تحمل رؤوسا
نوويه مهمتها الردع الاستراتيجي الشامل
ارضا وجوا وبحرا
كما كان الوضع من قبل سوف نل اهتماما
متزايدا لتقويه الثالوث النووي وسنواصل
والانتاج الضخم لانظمه كينجال الجويه التي
تفوق سرعتها سرعه الصوت ومن البحر سنبدا
في الامداد بكميات كبيره من صواريخ سيركون
والسلاح الاول منها هو الصاروخ سارمات
الارضي الذي يحمل عشره رؤوس نوويه وهو
نظام صاروخي استراتيجي من الجيل الخامس
ويتم استخدامه من قواعد ارضيه بضرب اهداف
على بعد الاف الكيلومترات باستخدام انواع
مختلفه من الوسائل الثابته والمتحركه
اما السلاح الثاني فهو مجمع صواريخ كنجال
الجويه التي تفوق سرعه الصوت والتي تعتبر
ايضا من احدث الاسلحه التي طورتها موسكو
ضمن الصواريخ الباليستيه التي تطلق من
الجو
حيث تبلغ سرعه هذا الصاروخ 12 الف كيلو
متر في الساعه وهو قادر على تدمير الاهداف
بمدى يصل الى 200 كيلومتر واخيرا سلاح
السيركون البحري الذي يعد اخطر اسلحه ثالث
الرضع النووي والذي لقب بالصاروخ الذي لا
يقهر حيث تكمل خطورته في الغواصات التي
تحمل والتي يمكنها التخفي في اعماق البحار
لاشهر قبل ان تطلق صواريخها كما انه قادر
على الوصول الى سرعه تساوي تسعه ارقام ماخ
ويبلغ مداه اكثر من 2000 كيلومتر لا يقتصر
الامر عند هذا الحد فروسيه تمتلك ايضا
انواعا مختلفه من السفن والغواصات الحربيه
المزوده بصواريخ نوويه عابره للقارات
والتي قد تلحق دمارا هائلا بشواطئ العدو
ومنشاته الساحليه سلطان العيبان العربيه
في اول مقابله من نوعها لوسيله اعلاميه
عربيه قالت سيده اوكرانيا الاولى اولينا
زيلنسكي ان لا احد يجهزك كسيده اولى خصوصا
في زمن الحرب مضيفه انها تحاول كل جهدها
للانتصار في هذه الحرب ضد روسيا
حسنا اولا وقبل كل شيء سابدا بحقيقه ان لا
احد يجهزك على الاطلاق كيف تكونين سيده
اولى خصوصا في حاله الحرب ولا احد يجهزك
لحقيقه انه يجب ان تكونين زوجه رئيس دوله
في حاله حرب ولكن كما قال داروين ليس
الاسرع او الاقوى من ينجو ولكن اولئك
الذين يمكنهم التكيف لذلك اعتقد انني اعمل
وفق متطلبات العصر حسب مقتضيات الظروف
التي نعيش فيها احاول ان افعل كل ما يجب
علي من اجل تقريب انتصارنا والشيء الاكثر
اهميه والتحدث عن اوكرانيا عن الاوكرانيين
في اي منصه حيث اتيحت للفرصه للتحدث
واتحدث سيده اوكرانيا الاولى للعربيه عن
لحظه الهجوم الروسيه على اوكرانيا وكيف
تحديدا انه تم من كل الجهات ودون سابق
انذار مشيره الى انها كانت لحظه انفصال
عائلتها لانشغال زوجها الرئيس زيلنسكي
بالحرب الناس بروبوكون لقد هجموا علينا
حقا من جميع الجهات في الصباح الباكر وكان
اصعب شيء بالنسبه لي هو كيف اقول للاطفال
كان علي ان اذهب الى الغرفه واوقظهم
واخبرهم بان الحرب قد بدات لكن لحسن الحظ
لقد استيقظوا بالفعل وفهموا بالفعل كل شيء
لم يكن علي ان اخبرهم باي شيء ومنذ تلك
اللحظه بدا زمن انفصال عائلتنا بعد ذلك لم
يروا والدهم الا بعد بضعه اشهر اليوم اكثر
من اي وقت مضى نتذكر ذلك التاريخ لا يوجد
تاريخ انتهاء لهذه الحرب لكن لها تاريخ
بدء وكان ذلك في الرابع والعشرين من
فبراير من العام الماضي وسوف نتذكر دائما
هذا اليوم الرهيب
مع الذكرى الاولى للحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا تتعالى الاصوات لتذكير الرئيس
الاوكراني بالاخطاء التي ارتكبها صحيفه
ولستريت جورنال اوردت تقريرا لابرز
الاخطاء التي ارتكبها زيلينسكي قبل الحرب
وبعدها
هنا في الجنوب الاوكراني وتحديدا في منطقه
خرسون وقف الرئيس الاوكراني قبل عام يهدئ
من هلع مواطنيه جراء الاخبار عن الحشود
الروسيه على طول حدود البلاد
اليوم وبعد عام من الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا تعود الاصوات لتذكير الرئيس
الاوكراني بما تسبب به للبلاد ليس كمسبب
للحرب بل على تجاهله الاعمى للتحذيرات من
غزو روسي كان وشيكا ومن الاخطاء التي
اعادت البلاد الى ايام الحرب العالميه او
اسوا يتذكر الاوكرانيون جيدا كيف وقف
رئيسهم هنا يدعوهم لعدم الضعر كان ذلك قبل
ان تصبح المنطقه باكملها بيد الروس فيما
عدا المدينه
يجب ان اتحدث مع شعبنا كرئيس واقول للناس
الحقيقه والحقيقه هي ان لدينا معلومات
مختلفه لكن افضل صديق للاعداء هم
المذعورون في بلدنا وكل هذه المعلومات
تساعد فقط فيه خلق حاله الذعر ولا تساعدنا
نحن
تقول وول ستريت جورنال ان زيلينسكي
وحكومته كان منشغلين بملاحقه الخصوم
السياسيين بتهمه الخيانه امر اثار استياء
الحلفاء الغربيين حينها وعندما بدات الحرب
لم يجد الاوكرانيون ما يدافعون به عن
انفسهم ورغم الحرب عاد الفساد ينخر حكومه
زيلينسكي وطفت على السطح قضايا فساد
مرتبطه بكبار مسؤول الحكومه والجيش اعترف
بها الرئيس في العالم
اليوم شهد الاوكرانيون مجموعه اخرى من
القرارات بشان الموظفين الفاسدين اؤكد على
اننا سنستمر في العمل على اي قضايا داخليه
تعوق الدوله الاوكرانيه من اجل الدفاع عن
البلاد والجهود المبذوله للتقرب من
الاتحاد الاوروبي رغم التاييد والتعاطف
الدولي للزنسكي لا تبدو اوكرانيا بين حرب
وفساد باحسن حال في عهده ليس بسبب غزو
روسيا بل لان اداره دوله لا تشبه التمثيل
والكوميديا وهو ما يقوله منتقد ومعارضوا
الرجل
نشرتنا مستمره وفيها بعض الفصل
في مقابله الخاصه مع العربيه عراب وبوتين
الكسندر دوغين يؤكد ان روسيا امام مفترق
طرق ولا يمكن لها ان تخسر الحرب
[موسيقى]
لانه تبين اندماج اوكرانيا في الناتو
والغرب كان اعماق لقد تم الرهان على عدد
من السياسيين المعارضين الاوكرانيين لكن
هذا الشيء لم ينجح اذ تم تقييدهم وتحيدهم
على الفور وجدت روسيا نفسها في حاله حرب
لم نقم مستعدين لها ولم نعول عليها
اذا في هذا الخبر العجله الاتحاد الاوروبي
يدعو الصين ويقول على الصين الدفاع عن
ميثاق الامم المتحده في مواجهات روسيا
وكانت الصين قد طرحت خطه للتفاوض مع بين
روسيا واوكرانيا
شدد المفكر الروسي المقرب من بوتين على ان
روسيا اصبحت امام مفترق طرق ولا يمكن لها
ان تخسر الحرب او تتخلى ايضا عن المناطق
الجديده مشيرا في لقاء مع العربيه الى ان
خساره روسيا في اوكرانيا تعني اندلاع حرب
اهليه
في هذه الحرب التي نخوضها مع الغرب هناك
مفترق الطرق التالي انها حرب خطيره لدرجه
ان روسيا لا يمكن ان تخسرها بل يمكنها ان
تنتهي لا يمكن ان تقول حسنا سنتخلى الان
على المناطق التي استولينا عليها حين ذلك
سيحدث انفجار داخلي ستطالق روسيا في حرب
اهليه لا يمكن لروسيا ان تخسر باي شكل
لانه بالتراجع خطوه الى الوراء سنتراجع
الف خطوه الى الوراء ستقاتل روسيا حتى
النهايه ببساطه لاننا لا نستطيع التوقف لا
يمكننا ان نخسر لن نكون راضينا الا عن
تحرير اوكرانيا باكملها من النخ السياسيه
المواليه لحلف الناتو مهما كان الثمن
افادت مصادر ايرانيه بان هجوما بواسطه
طائره مسيره استهدف سياره بالقرب من حديقه
عظيميه في مدينه كارجوست ايران ورجحت
المصادر ان يكون داخل السياره حامد عبد
الله قائد الوحده 400 وهي اهم وحده في
فيلق القدس والمسؤول عن تسليح الميليشيات
المواليه لايران ودعمها مليا ولم تشهر
المصادر حتى الان ما اذا كان قائد الوحده
400 حامد عبد الله قد لقي حتفه في عمليه
الاستهداف ام لا
اعلنت الحكومه الكنديه دعمها للمقيمين
الايرانيين المؤقتين في كندا الذين
يتطلعون الى تمديد اقامتهم على اثر قمع
الحكومه الايرانيه
للاحتجاجات الاخيره وقالت الحكومه الكنديه
في بيان لها ان هذه الاجراءات التي ستتخذ
اعتبارا من الاول من مارس ستسهل على
الايرانيين الذين يرغبون في تمديد وضعهم
المؤقت في كندا مما يسمح للايرانيين
بمواصله الدراسه او العمل او زياره الاسره
الاسره من خلال التقدم للحصول على تصريح
جديد من داخل كندا
في ظل ماساه الزلزال يبقى كثير من الاطفال
السوريين في تركيا دون العديد من الخدمات
الصحيه والطبيه لاسيما اللقاحات وازاء هذه
الحاله بدا موظف مراكز صحه صحه المهاجرين
المعنيون باللاجئين السوريين يصحبهم
متطوعون اتراك باستكمال اللقاحات للاطفال
السوريين في المخيمات جنوب تركيا
خرجوا الى الحياه مجددا بعدما عاشوا اهوال
الزلزال اطفال سوريون في الخيام افتقد
بعضهم الخدمات الطبيه الاساسيه في مخيمات
مدينه اصلاحيه بولايه غاز عنتاب موظفوه
مركز صحه المهاجرين المسؤول عن اللاجئين
ومتطوعون اتراك يجوبون الخيام بحثا عن
اطفال لم يتلقوا اللقاح بسبب الزلزال يحيى
متطوع تركي جاء من دوسجه شمالي تركيا
للمساعده في هذه المبادره
سالك نكمل لقاحات ناقصه للاطفال حديث
الولاده ولمن هم بعمر سته اشهر وتسعه اشهر
و12 شهرا نتفقد الخيام ونقدم خدماتنا لهم
كثير من العائلات السوريه لم تستطع تامين
اللقاحات لاطفالهم بسبب دمار لحق بمراكز
طبيه تعنى بهم
قال نحن من
على المخيم باركنا وبنتي ما جبنا لوحات
جينا هون ما في مراكز
صحه المهاجرين الحمد لله يعطيها العافيه
يجونا بنتي هون لا شك كانه جولاتة
المتطوعين وفرت حلا مؤقتا لمئات الاطفال
السوريين لكن الظروف القاسيه لذويهم تحتاج
المزيد من الرعايه والاهتمام خصوصا في ظل
غياب الكثير من الخدمات عنهم زيدان زنجلو
العربيه من مدينه اصلاحيه غازي عنتاب
في مصر افاد المعهد القومي للبحوث الفلكيه
والجيوفيزيقيه مرصد حلوان بان هزه ارضيه
ضربت مصر بعد منتصف الليل ومركزها السويس
وتحديدا
شمال المدينه واوضحها مرصد حلوان ان
الزلزال كان بقوه 4.1 درجه على مقياس رختر
وعلى عمق 10 كيلومترات وقال مواطنون في
القاهره والسويس ومحافظات وجه بحري
والقناه انهم شعروا بهزه ارضيه خفيفه
وصف نادي برايس المتحدث باسم الخارجيه
الامريكيه وصف قوه افاجنر بالمجموعه
المزعزعه للاستقرار وفي رده على سؤال
لمراسله العربيه حول تاثير المجموعه على
مسار الانتخابات الليبيه قال برايس ان
واشنطن فرضت عقوبات على قوات فاجنر
لمواجهه تاثيرها سواء في افريقيا او اينما
وجدت
مجموعه فاجنر اينما كانت في القاره
الافريقيه اوكرانيا او اي مكان اخر فهي
تجعل من هذه البلدان اضعف واكثر فقرا
وانعداما للامن واقل استقرارا وقد فرضنا
عليها عقوبات في محاوله لمواجهه تاثيرها
في اي مكان تتواجد فيه ونعمل مع شركائنا
لمعالجه انشطتها المزعزعه للاستقرار ان
كان ذلك عن طريق الانخراط بشكل ثنائي مع
البلدان التي تتواجد فيها او على صعيد
متعدد الاطراف علما ان التعاون الدولي
افضل وسيله لمواجه ه هذا التحدي
اعلنت كوريا الشماليه اطلاق اربعه صواريخ
كروز استراتيجيه باتجاه البحر في تجربه
قالت انها اظهرت مره اخرى القدرات الحربيه
للقوه القتاليه النوويه لديها وقالت وكاله
الانباء الكوريات الشماليه الرسميه ان
صواريخ الاربعه هي من طراز هو سال اثنين
اطلقت من محيط مدينه كيم تشيك في مقاطعه
الشماليه باتجاه بحر اليابان واضافت
الوكاله الكوريه ان الصواريخ اجتازت مسافه
كيلو متر قبل ان تصيب اهدافها بدقه من دون
ان تحدد ماهيه تلك الاهداف
الى العناوين
الامم المتحده تستبق الذكرى الاولى للحرب
بقرار يطالب روسيا بالانسحاب الفوري من
اوكرانيا
زلنسكي يقر بصعوبه الوضع على جبهات دومباس
وقمه افتراضيه لمجموعه السابع لدعم
اوكرانيا
خطه سلام صينيه تطالب بعدم اللجوء للنووي
والسيناف المفاوضات والتوصل لتسويه سلميه
بين موسكو
القاكم بعد دقائق
[موسيقى]